hey 42 here there are few places
on earth more mysterious than a circle
of standing stones
these giant chunks of rock known as
megaliths are a historic and scientific
conundrum i mean who in their right mind
would devote substantial time
to standing up tons of stone and why
there is a power in these megaliths an
air of mystery that
to this day causes rancorous debate
between scientists
historians and the slightly odd stone
sodomites
who visit these sites every summer and
winter solstice
awaiting the first rays of the morning
sun to split the earth in two
and out a tree priestess or ancient
druid as with all good mysteries
the major questions lie in the how
and the why why these stone circles
exist
all around the world from the british
isles across
europe and oddly in the horn of africa
in various configurations is still a
matter of hot
debate it seems however the arguments
divide between those all too familiar
combatants of
science v worship in the science camp
it's commonly postulated they were used
as astronomical observatories
circles such as stonehenge or the
ominous ring of brogdar
or stennis in orkney seem to be
precisely arranged in such a way
so they align with the movements of the
sun and moon
you know that feeling when you come up
with a revolutionary branch of
mathematics
only to be told that someone has beaten
you to it
well sorry pythagoras old mate but most
stone circles seem to have been built
with extraordinary geometric precision
well before you committed your theory to
papyrus
in 2016 gail higginbottom lovely surname
gail
from the university of adelaide
announced the results of her studies
of callanish on lewis and stannis on the
isle of orkney
in northern scotland using 2d and 3d
modelling techniques
she was able to confirm that the stones
aligned
perfectly with the sun and moon at
different times during their cycles
and these patterns repeated in standing
stone sites around the uk
around 50 percent of sites are aligned
with the summer solstice sun
and the other 50 with the winter
solstice
convincing though this argument may be
it still doesn't
completely piss on the chips of the
worship camp
paganism is steeped in its worship of
the sun and moon
and so rather than stone circles being
solely celestial observatories
they were likely places where people
gathered to celebrate and worship nature
cue the naked dancing hippies
naked moonlight dancing aside they also
served as a convenient
place to dump all the dead people there
have been countless
human bones found on sites of standing
stones
and we know the ashes of local people
were ritualistically brought to the
center of stone circles
and of course there was a healthy dose
of human sacrifice
at least we think the historicity is
slightly shaky here
and there were bloodlessing rituals and
practices to
contact dark forces from the other side
the other side of this world that is not
the neolithic
town centre why those pesky pagans
bothered building these back-breaking
structures may not be known
but what's slightly more interesting is
how they did it and a good place to
start our exploration of this little
poser
would be the most iconic in the world
stonehenge
the rocks our ancestors used to build
stonehenge consist of two distinct types
of stone
blue stone and the larger sarson
the blue stones are the smaller ones
weighing in at around two to five tons
each
and they form what was once the inner
circle
the larger sarson stones muscle in it
around 25
tons with the largest the heel stone
breaking the scales at a massive 30 tons
to equate that to elephants as one does
the heel stone weighs in at around four
and a half african elephants
or four and a half mammoths i suppose
would be
more historically appropriate the
enormous sauce and stones comprise
the outer circle with an additional
sauce and lintel above
each pair what's remarkable about this
ancient masonry
is that these historical lintels have a
tongue and groove shape
cut out to slot together as well as a
convex and concave system
to affix them atop the vertical stones
these intricate shapes are usually only
found
in woodworking she finds them in a stone
structure from
thousands of years ago no less is
nothing short of astonishing
now you'd think hefting these into place
would be
no walk in the park or should that be
planes
but these silly neolithic buggers only
went and made their lives more difficult
by being exceedingly picky about the
provenance of their materials
the lighter blue stones were transported
from the priscilly hills
in south west wales a whopping 155 mile
jaunt from stonehenge the 20 to 30 ton
sauce and stones were only brought down
from marlborough
a mere 20-mile journey but even with
this
short trip 30 ton blocks definitely fall
into the excess luggage category
furthermore stonehenge was built around
bc predating the arrival of the recently
invented wheel in britain by roughly 500
years
so how did they do it the most recent
idea is that the lighter blue stones
were transported
by water somehow shipped along the
bristol channel
which seems fairly logical however
from there on evidence for the remaining
land journey and construction phase
become a little hazy being built in
those bad old days before the wheel
archaeological theorists speculate that
log rollers were used
to shift the massive boulders over the
undulating landscape
vast numbers of logs were repeatedly
lifted and relayed
to create an endless conveyor belt
once in place the stones were thought to
have been raised by digging
pits and constructing pulley systems
consisting of large wooden a-frames
and ropes woven from plant fibres
still this all seems an extraordinary
feat
and rather enterprising for a society
that was a full
thousand years away from smelting bronze
and sticking said lump on stick to
better kill
other man who still has rock on stick
so naturally others have turned to more
imaginative theories presenting the 42
may or may not have built stonehenge
hall of fame
in first place aliens aliens either
lifted the stones with their big sexy
spaceships
or shared their knowledge with the dumb
earthlings
enabling them to do the grunt work
themselves
i mean yes give humans a technology to
lift huge stones
but don't give them i don't know a head
start on electricity or
you know the wheel next up is giants
the stones are big giants
are big makes perfect sense case closed
some translations of the bible do speak
of an ancient race of giants called the
nephilim
who was supposedly wiped off the earth
by noah's great flood
thoughts around giant involvement in
stonehenge's construction
can be slightly justified when we look
to the oldest surviving record of
stonehenge
dating from the 1100s the brute
chronicle
gives us the history of the founding of
britain by brutus of troy
and in this tome an image can be found
which depicts a giant
helping to build stonehenge ably
overseen
by none other than our final candidate
merlin yes our foreign legend is all
over stonehenge
so the merlin theory ties in very nicely
legend has it merlin and king arthur's
dad
ufo pendragon led a raiding party to
ireland to steal stones from a mystic
stone circle
called giants dance he then accio stones
them onto ships and back to salisbury
a simple reveling in the love he got
from dabbling with stone circles
some credit merlin as the creator of the
2000 plus standing stones
in cognac brittany rather than nicking
stones from other places this time
instead he used his magic to turn an
invading roman legion
into the wide variety of boulders that
make up this
of a worldly site that is some serious
magic
gandalf hang your pointy hat in shame
now whilst any of those could be true
and when i say
any i mean none most rational types have
come to the startling conclusion that
all megalithic constructions were built
by
a huge team of people working together i
mean it's not as if a
tuberculosis ridden skinny little man
could do it all by himself
could he well perhaps he could
today humans are busy building yet more
ugly housing estates and fast food
restaurants
rather than arranging pretty rocks in a
field except
for one man who only 100 years ago
built what is one of the only modern era
megalithic structures
coral castle encouraged to depart for
america
after being dumped by a 16 year old on
the eve of their wedding
yikes 28 year old latvian
edward leadskellen moved to florida and
immediately began construction of a top
secret project
he only worked under the cover of night
and alone
allowing no curious locals to catch a
passing glimpse
leedskallen was building himself a
castle from
nearby limestone and coral rock
furthermore
carving and lifting car-sized rocks into
place
or by himself wasn't enough he claimed
he was using no modern machinery only
primitive tools and wooden frames
naturally the locals all had the same
thought what the holy hell is that
latvian lunatic doing over there
and he really was a nut job he
distributed pamphlets around the
community
containing snippets of his political
opinions and social critiques
such as the schools and churches are
cheapening the girls
they are arranging picnics or coupling
up the girls with the fresh boys
and then they send them out to the woods
parks beaches
and other places so they can practice in
first degree love making
remember how only a minute ago i claimed
it would be
impossible for a tuberculosis-ridden
skinny little man to construct
a monolithic structure turns out i was
wrong
at one point lee skillin suffered from
life-threatening tuberculosis
but alleged that his mastery of
magnetism
had cured him completely of this deadly
affliction
was it this mastery of magnetism that
helped him levitate these massive blocks
using a technique his contemporaries
called reverse magnetism
or did he simply use his perpetual
motion holder
the tool he referred to when asked about
the construction
did lee skillin receive help from those
aliens
just like the builders the stonehenge
were alleged to these were all theories
tossed around by locals
and passed down for the decades sadly
the answer was
no no and definitely no
lead skill in may have been a shovel
short of a moat
but he was a dab hand engineer he
meticulously constructed a block and
tackle hoist
mounted on a large tripod made from
large tree trunks
enabling him to lift and maneuver the
stone blocks
sans levitation the various pulleys and
levers from which
are on display in the on-site museum
today
it was also pointed out that the
composition of the limestone and coral
rocks he used
were lighter than those of other ancient
standing stones
weighing in at a mere 15 tons
so it turns out that a middle-aged
american
could not have constructed weighty
megaliths like stonehenge by himself
unless of course your name is wally
wallington
a retired construction worker and
carpenter from michigan
wallington developed a fascination with
moving heavy objects by himself
i mean i suppose there are stranger
hobbies
somewhere wellington began moving heavy
blocks of stone
after discovering a nifty trick if he
placed a single rounded pebble
underneath the block he could rotate it
indefinitely
single-handed with little effort no
matter its weight
doubling down on this outstanding
achievement he added a second pebble
and realized that by rotating the block
a half
turn in each direction sequentially
he could move a one-ton block
horizontally
at 91 meters per hour wally was on a
roll
well more like a pivot but he would soon
be rolling
next he built ridged roads from wood
each ridge being the same width as the
stone block
mechanically this contraption was simple
but it meant when the block began to
roll
its momentum and weight kept it moving
archimedes famously said give me a lever
long enough
and a fulcrum on which to place it and i
shall move the world
well old wally wellington was a budding
greek polymath himself
because he said give me a rock and i'll
move your bard mate
that's right he moved his friends 30 by
50 foot barn 274 meters
by himself naturally the next step was
to construct his own stonehenge
he had mastered moving stone but not
raising them
so he devised a seesaw that used
counterweights
to enable him to stand gigantic blocks
single-handed so could a middle-aged
chap from michigan have answered the
question
posed by archaeologists for centuries
that is
how were these monumental stone circles
built
just by rolling up his sleeves and
pissing about in his garden
well it seems he just may have done but
even if our neolithic ancestors has this
insight
it's been estimated it still would have
taken some
30 million man hours to build stonehenge
if you want to visit these mystical
places
you'd better act fast because they're
slowly but surely
sinking into the ground especially
stonehenge
it was actually none other than charles
darwin who made the discovery
in 1877 he popped down to salisbury
plains
and noticed earthworms would burrow into
the soil at the base of the stones
and get busy feasting away then they
wiggle away from the stones
and deposits that earth up to several
meters away
this means the ground level is steadily
rising around the stones
causing them to sink some of the
prostrate stones
those that have fallen over may soon be
permanently covered with topsoil
nevertheless you've probably got another
few thousand years before those wiggly
bastards are done covering the whole of
this ancient place
thanks for watching you can now buy my
new book stick a flag in it on amazon
or get the audio book on audible you'll
find a link to both
in the description below thank you